hi
in this video we are going to talk about
the process of autophagy
autophagy is a greek word where auto
means self and phagy means eating
that means autophagy is a process in
which cell eats its own component it's
kind of like a cellular cannibalism
so autophagy involves the delivery of
cytoplasmic waste material let's say a
non-functional protein or a lysosome or
let's say a non-functional mitochondria
into a structure called autophagosome
eventually the autophagosome
is actually fusing with the lysosome
and thereby recycling the components
inside these
autophagosome it is important to
understand that autophagy is a
evolutionary conserved survival
machinery
from eukaryotes to prokaryotes every
cell can undergo autophagy under
stressed situation let's say a cell is
undergoing nutrient deprivation
under these circumstances cell need to
generate energy and that is done by
autophagy where it recycles the existing
nutrients and from that it generates
energy
now let us look at the mechanism of
autophagy and the context
to understand this process better
so autophagy starts with a molecular
step known as initiation and nucleation
a complex known as initiation complex
helps in this process
so the membrane that forms the
autophagosome is actually derived from
the endoplasmic reticulum
ah important kinase known as ulk 1 or
unk-like kinase 1 helps in this
initiation process
and
1 is actually an important regulator of
autophagy in a moment it would be clear
but once this initiation complex has
cleaved a little bit portion of the er
membrane a further complex known as pi3k
complex would be further elongating this
particular membrane and
it would be known as the nucleation
process so all of these steps are kind
of interrelated
in pi3 complex beccaline is an important
protein that we need to know but we
don't need to know
intricate details of all of these
proteins and how they in are involved in
this procedure we need to understand the
big picture
let us talk about the ulk kinase once
more so ulk kinase is regulated
by several physiological context such as
nutrient deprivation starvation etc
so let us imagine we are under a
situation of starvation so in this case
the atp and amp ratio would be altering
right atp level drops down whereas amp
levels are
rising up
these
relative change in atp to amp ratio is
sensed by molecular sensors such as amp
kinase
and amp kinase can activate ulk and
thereby activating the process of
autophagy it is kind of telling the cell
right now there is a nutrient
deprivation situation you need to
survive and start the process of
autophagy at the same time there are
other molecular regulators such as mtar
mtar is also a nutrient sensor whenever
there is too much nutrient is present in
the cell mtor would phosphorylate ulk
and inhibit ulk and prevent the
autophagy it's kind of telling the cell
that we have enough nutrient in store so
we don't need to recycle things to get
generate energy
makes sense right
but under nutrient deprivation amp
kinase would eventually activate
inhibitors of mtor and thereby promoting
the autophagy
or autophagy mechanism
next step of autophagy is elongation of
the isolation membrane and this process
involves several atg genes which are
involving in the autophagy process
this includes atg 12 htg5 and many more
one thing is really significant here is
the lc3
lc3 is an important regulator of
autophagy and lc3 is an important marker
to mark the cells which are undergoing
autophagy eventually lc3 gets converted
to lc32
and the autophagy
vesicle forms nicely and the
autophagosome is now ready to be fused
with the lysosome
eventually lysosome and autophagosome
fused to each other
and thereby the nutrient recycling take
place
now here we talk about only one type of
autophagy which is known as
macroautophagy but other than macro
autophagy there are other types of
autophagy like microautophagy chaperone
mediated autophagy and about these
processes i'm not getting into details
in this video but there would be
separate video on all of these processes
and you can get all this video in the
eye button very soon
now let us imagine a situation where our
body is undergoing star starvation
situation it's kind of like a stress to
our body
under prolonged starvation our body
would eventually perform autophagy let's
say we are starving for more than 16
hours
so our body would eventually
do autophagy
and it's like a recycling mechanism by
which
body can get all the essential energy
from the recycled nutrients
so let's say we have we need a
functional enzyme to
cope up with the stress
but this enzyme requires raw materials
like amino acids and amino acids can be
obtained from the foods but under
starvation situation we don't have food
availability right
so obviously where can these amino acids
be obtained
and the answer is simple
the autophagy mechanism would come into
play it would
take all the non-functional protein
degrade it get all the amino acids which
are the building block of the amino acid
and from that cell can build a
functional enzyme
it makes a lot of sense that how under
stress situation all the unnecessary
garbages can be recycled to make
whatever we need at that moment
so this is a minimalistic approach that
cell takes for efficient nutrient
recycling
it has been seen that under different
disease conditions like
neurodegenerative diseases like
alzheimer's disease the key pathology is
protein accumulation or amyloid pluck
scientists believe that these amyloid
pluck can be actually
recycled
if we induce the process of autophagy
but still it's a point of debate
now let us talk about or summarize the
physiological importance of autophagy we
already understood a little bit of that
but autophagy is a survival mechanism
that helps us to cope up with stress
environment and it's kind of like an
evolutionary conserved mechanism
autophagy can both promote cancer growth
or it sometimes it can also work against
cancer so active research is going on in
the field of cancer
many neurodegenerative diseases are
associated with the dysregulation of
autophagy process
many pathogens are degraded by autophagy
this includes mycobacteria shigella hsv1
etc
so overall what we have learned from
this video is dysregulation of the
autophagy can lead to several diseases
like inflammatory biology disease and
neurodegenerative disease and it can
also alter the way host interacts with
the pathogen
so if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to support
my channel on patreon you if you are an
indian viewer you can support my channel
by scanning this qr code and paying some
money to my channel so your small
contribution means a lot to me anyway
you can subscribe to my channel and
please share it with your friends my
detailed courses are also present in
unacademy you can use my code ap10 to
get a 10 percent off see you in the next
video thank you for watching